welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and after a huge
two weeks of stranger things reveals I
thought I'd take a look at one of the
alternate theories about the show's
ending as well as the evidence to
support it whilst the majority of people
including myself believe that the
post-credits scene of stranger things
reveals the fate of one of the key
characters has actually another big
possibility and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down all of the
evidence that shows that maybe not
everything is as simple as it seems now
from here or now returning the spoilers
up to 11 so if you haven't seen the
final episode of stranger things 3 and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now if
you're still here thank you so much for
clicking the video now let's get into my
alternate ending theory for stranger
things 3 okay so just a quick wrap-up of
what most people think happened at the
end of stranger things and the final
action scene of the finale we saw Jim
Harper trapped on the walkway that
housed the Russian weapon that was being
used to open it air into the upside down
Jim left with no real options escaped
through the doorway into the upside down
and then from here he was picked up and
come checked her through the other tear
that the Russians were seen to have been
creating in the opening of the first
episode he's held prisoner and is locked
away in a Cell whilst the other captives
around him are fed to the demo korkin it
all makes sense and seems pretty
straightforward however there's an
alternate theory that the American in
the cell could in fact be none other
than dr. Brenner
aka Elevens father but what evidence is
there to support this I mean Brenner did
die right didn't he well not really
whilst he was attacked by the demagogue
and at Hawkins middle school at the end
of season one similar to hopper his body
was never found and he was never killed
on camera you know the rule of TV comics
and Halloween movies right if there's
nobody and they're not dead in season
two eight brings up a projection of
Brenner to inspire 11 and there's also
some lip service paid to the fact that
he's still alive and out there in
addition to this there are several
interviews with the duffer brothers in
which they've confirmed that Brenner is
still alive and they even stated that he
would be making an appearance in season
3 though this never materialized or did
it well if he is the prisoner in the
cell then that means that he's still
made an appearance in some way in season
3 without actually being on screen
whilst I would love for the prisoner to
be hopper it doesn't really make much
sense that the Russians would actually
keep him alive
hopper can't really offer much of their
experiments and if he were to escape he
could blow the whole thing open
Brenna on the other hand is a master
scientist and the Russians would want to
keep him alive purely for the fact that
he could help improve their technology
and provide them with more ways to
access the upside down and build
psychics
there's even potential at Brenna has
been held captive by the Russians for a
long time and he is the real genius
behind their experiments xi has also
apparently lost her powers at this point
and we saw in season 2 that even just a
projection of him was able to get her
fired up once more and on a rampage in
season 4 Branagh could once again be
used as a way to make xi regain her
strength and become even more powerful
whilst I do think Jim Hoffa is alive
there's always been one point in my
theory that I've never been able to
explain and that is how did he get from
America to Russia in the upside-down
it's far too distant to travel and I
can't really see him making the journey
down but though I do think hopper did
flee to the upside down in the finale of
season 3 it doesn't mean that the brenna
theory is untrue either what if in the
finale we saw hopper hop into the upside
down and then from now we cut to Russia
to see Brenna in the cell it grants both
characters a way to come back and I
definitely think it works the more I
think about it the more it makes sense
and I can definitely see this being the
case when we get to season 4 obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
theory and if you agree with me or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the hidden voicemail message in
stranger things season 3 that gives us
some hope about how hopper could still
be alive I'll leave that linked at the
end and hopefully I'll see you over
there after this I also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the theory in the comments
below the winner will be chosen at
random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then
whoever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you